pat buchanan is a political and populist
legend he served into three presidents
including he was in the Oval Office with
Richard Nixon on the very evening of the
Saturday night massacre
I spoke with Pat earlier about whether
history may repeat itself over special
counsel Bob Muller and the state of the
trump presidency hey Pat how are you
good essentially your congratulations on
the new show thank you I mean I had to
invite the guy who kind of back in 1992
gonna reset the Republican Party or at
least try to back toward Reagan and all
those years later you have this guy
Donald Trump he didn't have the
pitchfork that ended up winning the
presidency in November and the same
people who were trying to drive you out
of the party are trying to drive Trump
down now on the right and they're out
there exactly but Trump ran on those
same issues we had back then that
matured secure the border no more
Foreign Wars unnecessary Wars and also
no more of these trade deals that are
exporting American jobs and factories
and Trump brand and B 15 or 16
establishment Republicans amazingly won
the election but you wouldn't know it by
listening to John McCain he was at the
US Naval Academy and gave a speech where
he talked about the isms and how
protectionism isolationism nativism are
taking over the Republican Party and how
the fake crackpot conspiracy theories
are dominating the national conversation
he's acting like you know Trump's the
problem not the solution but the point
is that that look John McCain is making
this case but the idea was we look we
lost all these jobs we lost these
factories what is wrong with protecting
American factories America's national
independent American sovereignty that's
what the American people voted but
you'll say Pat that that's not what the
Republican Party's history is but does
he know his history given what
Republican presidents have done visa vie
tariffs throughout the history of the
Republic exactly since Eisenhower and
Nixon we became a free trade party but
protectionism as the policy of Lincoln
the marilla tariffs they passed it ten
times during the Civil War tariffs were
in the America of protectionism was in
every Republican platform until 1948 how
do they think they built up this mighty
industry in the United States the
greatest in the history of
well how do the Chinese name me one
country in the world great country great
economy that built up its economy on
free trade well let's let's talk about
what McCain says about walls he said
look we tear down walls we don't put up
walls of course making the reference to
Reagan mr. Gorbachev tear down this wall
is that is that appeal would that be the
same John McCain who walked along the
border and said build the dang fence I
mean when he was running last time out
look the entire Western civilization the
issue of mass immigration from the third
world unchecked immigration is causing
countries all over the Western world to
build fences to build security fences to
control immigration Ronald Reagan said a
country that doesn't secure its borders
doesn't protect its borders isn't really
a country anymore what do you think
Reagan would think of all this today
where the party is where the Reagan was
a conservative of the heart I believe
let me what I mean he was intellectually
there but he was you know at one point
he did ask that people talked about all
the job you know about trade deals and
he says what happens to the workers I
mean when we ran in trouble with Harley
Davidson I remember we said Harley's
going under and he said why said the
Japanese are sending all these big bikes
they're dumping them in here to kill
Harley Davidson okay put a fifty percent
tariff on Harley
saved Harley and Reagan and a couple
months later was up there sitting on one
of the big horn little ponytails riding
all over that's a good thing let's talk
about this special council probe when
you have a low-level guy who was a
volunteer he was on one of these foreign
policy boards I've never heard of him
before George papadopolis they wired him
up it turns out and they sent him out to
try to set up meetings with Trump fo
campaign folks and so forth he pled at
back in early October he started
cooperating back in July right well like
this could this be a real problem for
the Trump agenda well let me just say
this look even with Papadopoulos there
is no underlying crime he didn't commit
any crime even if he had knowledge look
the Russians told me they got all these
emails and they're going to dump them
that's not a crime
his crime was lying quite frankly in
front this is a real difficulty I think
there's no underlying crime in this
whole alleged
illusion conspiracy and there's no
collusion between Trump and Putin but
there's a problem if people you call
people on the phone and you got that
wire on and he's been told what to say
this is the real problem I think for the
Trump administration legally but the
other one is this is going to be a
massive distraction I've done through
these things iran-contra once your
Watergate but for years and years and
years they go these these you mean I am
really against the whole special
prosecutor idea I think a constitutional
I agree these are mighty engines which
are directed to destroy presidencies
look and if the Congress of the United
States feels that Trump ought to be
impeached then impeach him you got the
constitutional obligation they say we
don't want it we don't want to decide
where to go to war we don't want to
decide what's you know the coinage you
turn that over to the Fed I mean the
Congress has abdicated enormous Lee and
this is one of those signs of abdication
one of the narratives that we're seeing
play out in the media and this is mostly
fomented by the left but picked up every
now and then by figures on the right
more of the establishment globalist
figures questioning Trump's fitness for
office he's seething they claim through
leaks of someone to the press they were
see was seething over the Muller
indictments yesterday he gets enraged
when when when people leaked he he gets
frustrated he's flying off the handle
they keep repeating that and I think
that's a big setup toward trying to
remove him from office I think they
wanted to do this from the very
beginning seeking to undo this populist
victory because it's working so far look
at the economy look at what's happened
with consumer confidence and in
percentage that that you know you
mentioned the economy it's looks again
you got the growth of three percent two
quarters in a row you got consumer
confidence as well you got money in the
stock market I'm sure you do it seems to
be doing fairly well thank god these are
all positive and this is one of the
things I will say that concerns me about
this investigation
if this gets gone and there's more
indictments and people say you know
Trump is going to be a broken president
and that's what happened of course the
economy went bad on Nixon 1973 after his
49th state landslide and when they do
that you know then all the Jackals come
out and they say we can get him
but you know I I just don't see it right
now because as I say the Papadopoulos
thing I mean I don't know what the guy
did other than tell a lie but what he
didn't do and meanwhile you have fusion
GPS you have Anthony Podesta resigning
from his Democrat consulting lobbying
firm John's gonna follow pretty soon
yeah Dancing with the Stars but you know
but that's that's really if they see the
Russians gave material to this
Christopher Steele who's the British
agent who gave it diffusion GPS which
got it spread all over this city in
these this dosi air you have Russians
involved in it you had the Democrats in
pedestrian ran the campaign and
Wasserman Schultz and they paid the
money the 12 whatever million dollars is
taken out of it and they said well we
didn't ask what they did with the money
that's not credible so I think I do
believe that I mean this is something
that motor himself ought to be
investigated because it is an example of
Russians interfering in the American
election frankly to damage Trump Gregg
Gregg Sargeant today and the Washington
Post was saying this is all Republican
you know wild theories about deep state
and they're trying to deal Ajith
amaizing men and women of the FBI and
they're trying to work against the the
traditional professionalism of the FBI
and Bob Muller who apparently no one can
ever criticize Bob Muller is a you know
should be up on Mount Rushmore and he's
arguing that this is just a tactic being
used by Republicans again to undermine
an ongoing investigation you know I've
never seen a city even including 1974
and Watergate
they were so hateful and hostile toward
encodes it worse than what Nixon idea
says mean Nixon at the very end it was
as bad there was really enthusiasm for C
and Nixon go down destroying the guy you
can get there's a smell of blood you
know the scent of blood is in the
nostril why what's behind that Pat
what's really behind behind what the
media the left and the globalists and
the party are trying to do Donald Trump
came to Washington DC and stole what the
Republicans thought was going to be
their turn and he's taken away the
leadership in the of the country and
they can't stand the guy and I think
they mean I've never really ever seen
this but they
determined to break this man and to
bring him down and to finish him up look
Donald Trump got 4% of the vote in
Washington DC you think this is not a
hostile City for 4% Wow that was
probably just my vote no you know my
relatives
let's talk before we let you go about
this idea that Trump is like thinking of
or toying with the idea are grappling
with firing Muller of course that brings
me back to your days in the oval office
with Richard Nixon on the night of the
Saturday night massacre tell us tell us
about whether that means he he has a
constitutional right to do it no doubt
about it especially counsels in the
executive branch but that would set off
a huge fire Nixon had no choice I mean I
wrote him that morning I said you're
gonna have to fire
Richardson because Richardson and my
judgment turned on us he said he would
fire Cox if Cox didn't accept a deal and
so I'm so Richardson says I'm not going
to do it
you know if I'm gonna stand by Cox and
we had Henry Kissinger in Moscow you had
the Middle East war going on at that
time
Nixon's tellin Brezhnev I'm you know I
will move in the middle east if you do
so you got no choice mr. president so
Nixon calls me over to the Oval Office
at 3:00 in the afternoon and he says
I've got Henry over there with breasts
now what does the president I'm going to
say if I let the Attorney General of the
United States Buffalo me and bold me and
make me back down he's got to go and so
we talked about it for about 45 minutes
and he said you better go out this way
because Elliot's coming in this way with
Haag and so I went out this way and
there was my friend Elliot Richardson I
said hi Elliot how are you and he had
this sort of smile on his face and Haig
had his head down like a sheriff leading
someone to execution as he walked in and
and got hammered by Nixon I went over to
this restaurant over here where they had
the roller skates and everything and I
told two friends of mine in town
there'll be impeachment resolutions in
the house on Tuesday and sure enough
they're about twenty of them next
Tuesday yeah I doubt that that would
happen I had urged Nixon to burn the
tapes three months before and to get rid
of Archibald Cox before he'd been built
up but by then he had this huge
operation the press was covering him so
it was a just another wise Trump today
don't do it I would say don't do it pat
buchanan my friend all right appreciate
ur